[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand j'étais petit je me rappelle de ce
jour où la maîtresse nous avait
rassemblé pour nous poser cette fameuse
question les enfants qu'est ce que vous
voudrez faire plus tard savait qu'on
vous serez plus grands et comme souvent
ce jour-là ya eu des clans qui sont
formés les médecins des architectes les
avocats les pompiers des footballeurs
les acteurs les blogueurs et non je
rigole personnes voulaient faire
blogueur quand il était plus jeune
même pas moi non moi j'étais un original
je me rappelle ce jour là je peux passer
en dernier avec mon grand sourire je
passe au tableau alors moi quand je
serai plus grands je voudrais être
dictateur comme vous toute la classe
s'est foutu de ma gueule ce jour-là est
en fait ce qui est intéressant j'avais
10 ans et quand on a dix ans nous arrive
parfois de confondre des mots qui
sonnent pareil on pense que c'est des
synonymes
par exemple canicule et clavicule écoles
et alcool quand encore ma mère et ma
soeur annonce à sa petite juste dont
nord pas de calais
je viens de lille j'ai l'habitude vous
pouvez y aller et donc c'est ce jour là
où j'ai pris conscience à quel point les
enfants peuvent parfois être méchant et
dur heureusement que la maîtresse était
là soit qu elle était gentille madame da
silva et du coup cette histoire n'a bien
évidemment rien à voir avec le sujet ma
conférence le sujet qui est sous forme
de questions à deux choix
êtes vous un spectateur ou un joueur
fait l'idée principale c'est quoi ces
j'aime bien voir la vie comme un jeu
voyez est comme un jeu on aurait le
choix entre deux modes spectateurs et
joueurs on peut choisir que l'un ou
l'autre on peut pas choisir les 2 en
même temps et malheureusement on passe
la majeure partie de notre vie dans ce
mode spectateur tous tiens par exemple
en sortant du resto était pas mal cette
blanquette de veau mais le strabisme du
serveur m'a un peu gêné deux étoiles sur
cinq
cet été par exemple c'est vrai que
l'hôtel est pas mal situé mais il a fait
mouche le 3e et le 4e jour une étoiles
sur cinq
ces exemples là c'est des vrais avis que
des vrais êtres humains ont vraiment
laissé on peut on imaginer d'autres par
exemple
après cette conférence en sortant c'est
vrai que c'était pas mal trouvé son truc
de spectateurs et joueurs mais je sais
pas si tu as vu il y avait sa braguette
qui était ouverte pendant tout le truc
bref du coup on se concentre s'il vous
plaît l'idée vous l'aurez compris c'est
simple en fait de juger les autres et du
coup j'ai pensé à ce qu'on fasse tous
ensemble une expérience qui a jamais été
tentée auparavant dans une salle de
spectacle ni dans une salle de
conférence pour une fois s'arrête moi
qui vais vous jugez qui vais vous mettre
des notes en tant que spectateur par
exemple toi t'as pas rigoler sur mes
blagues une étoiles sur cinq
toi tu rigole encore sur dictateur cinq
et trois sur cinq
je peux continuer comme ça mais au foot
ce mode spectateur n'est pas si génial
que ça on est une génération qui se
prend les pieds dans le tapis
mais surtout on est une génération qui
passe en une grande partie de notre vie
à vivre des expériences par procuration
on va regarder des vidéos suivre des
séries regarder des films jouer à des
jeux vidéo et on a vraiment l'impression
de vivre des expériences extraordinaires
puis on juge on a un avis sur tout on
critique les gens qui passent à l'action
il ya peut-être quelqu'un ça lui a pris
cinq ans pour monter un film trouver les
financements les acteurs le scénario
puis nous en 10 secondes
on va dire ouais bof c'était pas mal et
[Musique]
je vous propose une meilleure expérience
je vous propose que ce soit vous ce soir
en tant que spectateur qui passe y est
en mode joueur et pour ça c'est ma
partie préférée je vous ai préparé trois
défis collectifs qu'on va tous faire
ensemble ce soir là maintenant le
premier défi je les appelais changer sa
posture physique
c'est vrai que la posture physique qu'on
a tendance à avoir va refléter notre
état psychologique
par exemple quand on est fatigué on va
se tenir comme ça un peu recourbé quand
on est triste en vain - sourires mais
l'inversé vrai s'ouvrir va nous mettre
dans une certaine psychologie dans un
certain niveau d'énergie se tenir droit
pareil vous verrez jamais james bond
arrivé comme ça un martini s'il vous
plaît et du coup le premier défi que je
vous ai préparé c'est tous à partir de
maintenant et pour la suite de ce talk
de vous tenir droit et on va ajouter une
difficulté supplémentaire
il ne faut plus à partir de maintenant
que votre dos touche le dossier du siège
jusqu'à la fin
et voilà ajouté un petit truc si vous
voyez que votre voisin ou votre voisine
600 d'eau touche le siège ils vous dois
un restons sortant juste de ce talk
c'est plutôt sympa vous voyez déjà vous
parlez entre vous et juste petit
changement d'état d'esprit on sort un
peu de son mode spectateur et on est
vraiment acteur et on va pouvoir
enchaîner avec le deuxième défi montez
un peu en puissance et on va vivre une
expérience ce soir où on va tous faire
une conférence en même temps ça n'a
jamais été fait peut-être parce que
c'est le bordel mais on va tester le
deuxième donc défi c'est prendre un
engagement public
j'ai récemment lu une étude très
sérieuse
une étude scientifique est donc faite
par des scientifiques comme son nom
l'indiqué est du coup c'est une étude
disait la chose suivante
incroyable le simple fait de noter nos
objectifs de les mettre sur papier de
les formaliser ce simple fait c'est
simple action qui va nous prendre
peut-être moins de 12 minutes
mais cette simple action va augmenter
nos chances d'atteindre nos objectifs de
40 % 40 % les amis maintenant imaginez
si en plus de cette formalisation si on
utilisait le pouvoir de la pression
sociale et l'engagement public pour dire
à nos copains nos amis mon défi c'est de
faire ça dans un an sur les réseaux
sociaux les utiliser à bon escient et
dire les gens je m'engage à faire ce
défi là où atteindre tes objectifs avec
telle date
et du coup ce qu'on va faire tous
ensemble c'est à 3 on va tous levé le
bras comme le gosse que j'étais et on va
dire je choisis le mode joueurs aller 1
2 3
yes yes c'est bizarre mais et c'est bon
qu'est-ce que je vous ferai pas faire le
troisième défi c'est de se concentrer
sur soi même et quelque part sortir de
ce mode juge et on a tendance mois par
exemple
il m'arrivait de lire un livre de
développement personnel ou une
biographie ou lire un article
et de remarquer que l'auteur avait fait
une petite faute et de passer
complètement à côté de l'expérience
et là je vous vois que vous n'êtes pas
concentré depuis thaler y en a certains
bons et les deux qui regardent encore
madrague est
mais les autres sont concentrés sur
cette faute que bien évidemment j'ai
fait de manière consciente
donc à partir de maintenant je vous
propose pour les cinq minutes qui vont
rester qu'on sorte de ce mode de juge
pour être dans un mode spectateur et se
poser la question suivante tous ensemble
à votre avis pourquoi faut-il sortir de
sa zone de confort
je vois que cette question vous perturbe
on va là posé autrement
à votre avis est ce que tout le monde
doit sortir de sa zone de confort
surtout vous bousculez pas accès on est
en mode joueurs les gars allez
je suis assez d'accord avec avec vous
oui mais je rajouterais un petit mais
moi les personnes qui sont heureuses
avec leur situation actuelle avec des
petites choses dans un confort dans une
routine dans une certaine sécurité
stabilité
ses personnages sont mes héros je les
admire parce que si je pouvais être
comme eux s'il existait une drogue ou un
médicament tu me dis tu prends ça des
heureux demain avec un métro boulot dodo
des heureux avec un scénic un labrador
et de gosse à la campagne je la prends
direct la drogue parce qu'elle est notre
objectif dans la vie tous ici et à
l'extérieur c'est d'être heureux et le
fait d'accumuler des expériences de
rencontrer un maximum de personnes de
voyager de sortir de sa zone de confort
tout ça c'est que des moyens pour
arriver à cette finalité là on n'a pas
choisi notre expérience nos expériences
passées notre enfance nos objectifs nos
ambitions mais s'il ya quelque chose
qu'on peut sur lesquels on peut
influencer
c'est bien sûr le passage à l'action
j'aimais bien cette phrase
cette définition d'einstein il
définissait la folie comme le fait de
faire tout le temps la même chose et
d'attendre un résultat différent et une
majeure partie des personnes qui sont
dans une certaine situation doit compris
pendant des années on est frustré on va
chercher des excuses externe en valeur
dans un mode on va en vouloir au monde
on vouloir aux personnes qui donnent des
conseils en vouloir aux conférenciers
qui laissent leur braguette ouverte en
vouloir aux auteurs qui font des fautes
d'orthographe
au lieu de se concentrer sur le fait que
pour changer notre situation
la seule solution c'est de passer dans
ce mode joueurs et d'oser sortir notre
zone de confort mais bien sûr ça
sous-entend qu'il ya quelque chose dans
la situation actuelle qu'on souhaite
changer qu'on a cette vision cette
ambition qu'on a quelque part c'est en
vie ce besoin
en fait je me rends compte d'un truc ça
fait peut-être dix minutes que je suis
en train de vous parler mais je suis
complètement malpolis monsieur même pas
présenté je m'appelle hanine j'ai 30 ans
et vous bon c'est vrai qu'il ya des
limites à ce mode joueurs mais en tout
cas il ya eu ce jour en 2005 qui a
complètement bouleversé ma vie et c'est
le jour où j'ai appris l'existence d'une
discipline qu'on appelait l'amélioration
personnel ou le développement personnel
si vous préférez et cette découverte a
complètement bouleversé ma vie j'étais
littéralement fasciné par ce monde de
nouvelles possibilités qui s'offraient à
moi où j'étais plus catégoriser en tant
que team i dont on peut réserver en tant
que personne qui va rester dans sa
classe sociale
mais tout ça n'était qu'une étape
intermédiaire dans ce jeu de la vie je
pouvait influencer sur mon destin dix
ans plus tard j'ai lu 300 livres j'ai
assisté à des dizaines et des dizaines
de conférences
j'ai regardé plein de vidéos et j'ai dû
appliquer à l'est moins de 1% de tout ce
côté théorique que j'accumulais jusqu'à
ce jour de 2015
c'est en décembre et on se moque pas je
fais partie de ces personnes qui en fin
de chaque année font une liste de ce
qu'on appelle les bonnes résolutions je
préfère les appeler des objectifs et fin
2015 je vais commencer par 15 objectifs
qu'un chose que j'aurais bien aimé faire
accomplir dans l'année ça s'est
transformé en 20 puis 30 40 50
et c'est là où j'ai eu cette idée tient
ce qui serait marrant c'est pendant une
année
pendant 365 jours c'est de faire un défi
par jour pour sortir de ta zone de
confort
certains jours ça pouvait être des défis
tout simple c'est une bandé les yeux et
être dans la peau d'un aveugle chez moi
pendant une demi journée
c'est de partager un sandwich avec le
sans abri qui traînait en bas de chez
moi depuis des années c'est tout
simplement lire un nouveau livre sur la
spiritualité alors que je me définis
c'est comme quelqu'un de cartésien ça
pouvait être aussi des défis qui
demandait un peu plus de préparation
sauter en parachute courir un marathon
prendre mon sac à dos et partir à
l'improviste
on tire on en sort une destination au
hasard et le projet personnel goodbye
conforte zone s'est très vite
transformée en une communauté de
personnes qui partageaient aussi comme
moi sur les réseaux sociaux
leur défi avec des photos avec des
articles et on est devenus plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
partageons cette même vision de
dépassement de soi et sorties de zone de
confort et surtout ce qu'on partage et
c'est qu'il est possible de s'amuser on
se dépassant que ce n'est pas forcément
quelque chose de chiant ou qu'il faut
faire des efforts pour nos 40 ans pour
éventuellement un jour arriver à cette
destination là qui n'existent pas parce
que derrière il une autre destination et
ceara et c est ma plus grande
frustration personnelle et chez ces
personnes là que je rencontre après les
conférences qui m'écrivent qui qui
commande ce que je fais c'est cette peur
qui revient tout le temps cette peur du
regard des autres du jugement des autres
parfois même c'est les parents c'est un
conjoint c'est des amis dont on a peur
pour prendre une décision faire une
reconversion professionnelle prendre une
décision un peu ambitieuse parfois c'est
des inconnus
oser se lancer dans un blog écrire un
livre faire une vidéo et avoir peur des
critiques des autres et parmi ces
gens-là ya des entrepreneurs des génies
potentiel des artistes de dingue
il ya peut-être des astronautes des
blogueurs soyons fous et autant de
personnes extraordinaires d'être humain
extraordinaire de père de mère de
famille extraordinaire qui parfois
n'osent pas prendre certaines certaines
décisions par peur du jugement des
autres
par peur de ses spectateurs parce que
j'ai oublié de vous préciser quand on
choisi ce mode spectateur
automatiquement et qu'on passe en mode
joueur
automatiquement il se passe la chose
suivante et des spectateurs qui vont se
tourner vers nous
et qui vont commencer à regarder notre
parti parce que le spectacle c'est là où
ça se passe et parfois pour certains ils
vont se permettre de juger de critiquer
sans avoir de contexte de la situation
j'ai revu ma soeur il ya deux semaines
son transition comme on dit et on
n'habite pas dans les mêmes pays donc on
se voit une à deux fois par an et là on
s'était vus on s'est fait un resto puis
après on est allé dans un bar pour
rattraper le temps
boire un verre et il s'est passé ce truc
là il y avait un mec ivre mort qui
arrivé comme ça sur notre table et qui
s'est mis comme ça pendant 20 secondes
sans rien dire mais ivre mort c'est un
miracle qu'il tienne sur ses deux pattes
et après ses vingt secondes
il s'est tourné vers moi il me fallait
faut pas être timide choper vous les
amoureux et même dans le nord ça choque
et ce mec là il est reparti par la suite
je vais pas ce qu'il est devenu
c'est peut-être endormi à côté de la
cuvette des chiottes mais bref ce qui
est intéressant c'est dans la vie il y
aura toujours des personnes qui n'ont
pas conscience du contexte externe qui
vont arriver dans une certaine situation
dans une partie quand on est le héros de
notre propre vie et qui vont se
permettre de juger sans avoir de
contexte et au final qu'est ce que ça on
dit ça on dit plus sur leur état actuel
que sur vous même et s'il ya bien un
domaine dans notre vie où il faut et
dictateur c'est bien dans notre vie on
va pas commencer à faire des sondages à
chaque décision d'autant plus que la
plupart de nos décisions l'impact que
nous mêmes donc choisi sont les mots de
joueurs de mode joueurs les amis
amusons-nous sortant notre zone de
confort et soyons des dictateurs la vie
est un jeu
[Applaudissements]